when you played baseball this was so
the sami sosa mark maguire thing
happened it was 98 i believe right
so you come the year after i remember um
that that that was like uh luis gonzalez
was on the diamondbacks and hit like 56
home runs and it was like the first time
he ever hit over 30.
that's that's what it is you know what
was going on yeah
i ain't never get caught so i mean come
on i mean we got a [ __ ] world
series in one you know what i'm saying
yeah
but it was just a it's it was a
historical
time in baseball because i'm always i'm
for the steroids for the record
that's what they say definitely let
everybody just look do what the [ __ ]
y'all one more time
hey you know how much better the ratings
would be if everybody was jacked up
they let them do steroids then they
tighten the balls up you know what i'm
saying so it was like
just jumping that's why you were saying
was there like we always hear about
um cheating going on
the astros just had that cheating
scandal that was crazy
we hear about people corking their bad
[ __ ] like that with that kind of [ __ ]
that could be happening
i was playing against sammy sosa today
when his back got croaked you know what
i'm saying like oh you were there yeah i
was in left field
so i'm sitting there like yeah what's
that you don't say
now he's a white guy you see that
[ __ ] sammy sosa
[ __ ] yeah he looks like a cuban michael
jackson man
he pink now at this point yeah we like
man
he hit all these homers already he's
cooking his back
how much more does he need yeah so that
just goes
to show you man hey if you ain't
cheating you ain't trying that's what
they say